[Music]
I'm entered as if you didn't know me
already
this is me so my background academically
is in pharmacology my bachelor's was
pharmacology in genomics and I did my
PhD in pharmacology of which I've mostly
been involved in preclinical and
clinical validation of drugs so that
involves cells animals and humans and
I've worked with them all and the talk
I'm giving today is by analyzing the
electrocardiogram so back a few years
ago I worked for a biotech with Verona
Pharma PLT and as part of their normal
clinical validation or any normal
clinical clinical validation you have to
do cardio toxicological studies to check
that the effect of the drug doesn't
cause adverse effects on the autonomic
nervous system of which we use that the
ECG is kind of a reference point for
that the ECG is a famous waveform if you
ever see a medical company and they're
using on their logo they probably use
the ECG it's a really nice signal if
you're looking to dip your toes in this
and have done anything with
physiological data before the ECG offers
a lot for you so we refer to the bits
the ECG with these markers pqrst right
and the reason it's named like that is
because it's just calculus right they've
started at P and they've gone along and
said BK a peak their peak their bigness
what it relates to physiologically is
one of three four events inside the
heart so that little P waves are the two
little chambers of your heart your
Atreus contracting and pushing the blood
from the smaller part into your
ventricles the big one in the middle is
your ventricles they're the larger two
large chambers of your heart which eject
the heart around your body and create
the circulation system and the T wave
which is all important is a
repolarization step that occurs so the
electrical signal the action potential
that is generating your heart is created
by the simultaneous opening of ion
channels there and in order to reset
them so the next beat can occur it needs
to go to a repolarization which is
basically it it drags the voltage of the
membranes of the cells below a certain
threshold and the swee sets the channels
and of course if you don't reset the
channel this is actually one of the main
mechanisms by which
tricular arrhythmias propagate a normal
ECG looks a bit like this you have a
number of ECG waveforms and that are
constant in a row your heartbeat of
course is the distance between those two
large R peaks at that point when the
main ventricles beats is also the same
point where your blood pressure goes to
its systolic peak so that's the largest
bit and so as a result it's if you're
using a PPG sensor inside your smart
launch something of that nature this is
the thing it measures it measures that
tool peak in the middle and what makes
it quite useful from the signal
processing point of view is that's the
thing you look for first and then from
around there you know where an ECG beat
is and then you can find the beginning
and the end of it and in fact the
trickier part is often finding where the
beginning of the peak start and where
they end rather than finding the main
points which I'll come on to a bit later
I recorded my ECG at home so back in
2009 I found that a company that
distributes medical and biomedical
equipment so I have the stuff at home
which is fun probably the reason why I
started it and so the way you record it
ordinarily is you have a small Bach box
which has an amplifier and analog
digital converter you put the electrodes
over your heart
and you get the characteristic waveform
now I should probably point out that if
you were doing this in you know in a
classic sense this is how the first ECG
was recorded this is Vilhelm I told them
and he is famous because well he
basically discovered the ECG and you'll
also find there are certain parts within
Cardiology which refer to this guy so I
know fins triangle is named after this
guy and of course instead of having
electrodes stuck over his heart he's put
his hands into buckets of salty water
which actors have electrodes and then
his foot which is for his ground and
then all the signals get processed and
thrown on to a carbon drum so it is it's
old-school so if you if you want to find
yourself a nice steampunk project for
the weekend you can do it like I know
them did the placement of electrodes
gives you the characteristic shape and
the ones that I record today are at v2
lead 2 tends to give you the
characteristic shape and it's referred
to if you were googling for it as a
three lead ECG as opposed to a 12 lead
ECG where you put twelve leads all
around
and you use that as a way of getting
different planes of electrical signal at
the time that it beats and that can give
you better capacity to make certain
clinical diagnosis so the library's I'm
going to use up today it's really gonna
be a showcase about the core library
using Python to do this kind of work in
the pharmaceutical and research space
MATLAB is still very very popular and
I'm here to basically say it's really -
because you have everything you need out
of the box of which I point out a few of
things which are replacements for things
you might use inside of MATLAB which you
can use here which I think work very
well in fact peak utils
which I use for some of the peak finding
bits is almost directly copied from the
signal processing toolbox inside of
MATLAB so that works out quite well
grant so I'm a big fan of loading my
data out of hdf5 if you're going to
choose a binary format to store your
physiological data in I can't recommend
it enough it has a bunch of decent
compression chunking algorithms as well
as having some decent interfaces for
reading the files directly into a numpy
array one of the reasons why numpy array
is so fast is it adopts a contiguous
block of memory and especially when
doing ECG analysis a lot of it is doing
slices and views over your raw data set
so of course if you have something's in
the contiguous block of memory and just
move the pointer around it works a lot
faster so this sets you up just fine
this is a live code so here we go
so there we go load it and then I've ran
this before there we go so here's my ECG
that I recorded at home and if you use
the matplotlib notebook magic method you
can also get all the tools that you used
to get on the desktop inside the browser
so there we go you can see this classic
ECG peek and really what I'm trying to
show you at this point
is that of course when you record it in
real life it doesn't look anything like
the diagram you saw earlier and that's
what we're going onto next filtering and
preparing the signal to actually some
analysis on it so the reason we have the
processor is there are lots of other
electrical noises which are going to be
recorded at the same time as your ECG
your ECG is a signal for about 1
millivolt down to about half a millivolt
of which your muscles are generating
millivolts around you
you'll be picking up all sorts of
information from inductive noise you get
a baseline shift because of respiration
so whenever you breathe your chest
inflates it compresses your heart
slightly that affects some of the
vasculature around your heart which then
has an effect on the ECG which is what's
quite fun is that you can record
respiratory measures from your ECG which
people have used before which is quite
nice so if you're using a chest belt to
do respiration just take an ECG that'd
give you bass yeah
so next when we go on to the trending
and built in the signal so the first
thing I've done here is d-train during
the filtering with a Butterworth filter
and the reason I do this is this is
basically a kind of the mainstay way of
doing it
medically even though it's not the best
way of doing it so to point this out
what we're doing is that we are applying
a bandpass filter over our signal
because we're not going to we don't need
all the frequencies that we've recorded
for an ECG you maybe want to go from
zero to about a hundred Hertz that
covers pretty much everything you'd want
to see after you've filtered your signal
it is likely that you might want to see
it smooth because if you're going to be
looking as we are today where the peaks
occur then by smoothing signal it gives
us a much sharper definition of where
the peak is again this is basically the
kind of way you would do it medically
it's not the best way I'm going to go on
to talk more about that but effectively
what we've got here is we've got the
signal the one at the top is my raw
signal the one in the middle is one
after I applied my filtering and you can
see it's taken out some of the high
frequency components we don't need and
then the smoothing gets a little bit
closer to that now of course in the
situation where you can't really now see
all the different peaks and parts part
of this is an issue with reporting ECG
in the first place you'd like to think
your heart is sitting there nice and
static but actually for the small amount
of room for it to rotate slightly so one
of the issues that can occur is you've
got one electrode if you're doing a 3d
ECG and it's moved slightly out of
orientation to pick up one of the peeps
you might be looking at so if you're
looking at for instance wanting to
measure the width of the QRS complex
fairly important if you're looking at
myocardial infarction things of that
nature then you're going to want to make
sure you have multiple leads which is
why clinically there are multiple leads
if so we can get so this event of the
operating slightly doesn't cause us so
much of an issue wavelets is basically
what I'm coming on to you now so
Butterworth filters is where you'll have
stuff if you have a medical device but
primary research is basically already
found that wavelets are fantastic for
both filtering and determining the
signal but also for giving identifying
Peaks within that signal how many people
here are familiar with wavelets and
wavelet transformations cool good that I
was pleased that I chose to then explain
what wavelets were so and you can take
here what I've done is I've taken a
single slice of the ECG so I've taken
I've already found out where ECG be once
slice that value and then the next thing
that I've done is a wavelet
decomposition so if I do good you can
kind of see it so this uses the pi
wavelet package so if you're using the
wavelet toolbox inside of matlab this
actually gives you most of what you need
so a bit like a Fourier transform which
you might be familiar with where you're
taking a complex sinusoid and
translating it and transforming it into
the base components of that sinusoid
wavelets take a wave form and decompose
it into wavelets smaller parts which
describe the wave form and it does that
by convolving one type of wavelets
through your signal and then giving you
a signal out at the other end and the
reasons why these work particularly well
in this situation is that wavelets are
discontinuous they can you can be used
for approximating sharp edges much
better
whereas FFT works really well if your
signals are smooth or if the ultimate
underlying thing is a smooth continuous
periodic waveform which in the case of
an ECG it's sort of periodic but the
actual opening of channels in your heart
is a probabilistic function so you get
quite a bit of noise and
non-deterministic part it's thrown into
this I think this is partly why wavelets
work so well is because they amass that
situation much better so what we've got
here is I've run a debauchees wavelets
you don't really need to understand what
the choice of wavelets i've got here
simply that's a good one
you could do an entire talk about
choosing the best wavelet for your given
signal and what it's done here is
everything it's gone through convolving
wavelet once twice third a number of
times a number of times that I've set
in the number of levels that I want to
run the way that through and from this I
can get a small signal that either I can
run my peak detection on or I can use
that to find a particular feature that I
could then run through my signal to
discover something that I want I also
think that's one of the things that
works out quite nicely in flavors
designing them yourself is often the
case of drawing the shape you want I'll
help you find the shape that you need
inside the signal and then to sort of
complete the package is that you would
ordinarily break your signal apart into
wavelets convolve it through and then
what you then choose to do is so in this
case right if I take all the wavelets
that I had and I combine the back
together I get my original signal but if
I take only a few of the wavelets then I
can get for instance here is a lossy
filtered signal which looks a lot more
like the ECG that I wanted right this is
how if you apply this to a 2d shape this
is how they achieve jpeg2000 is you run
your wavelets through your image you
find the ones either a small or part
components and you can remove them from
your signal so this can also be used to
compress ECGs and this is when it's done
ordinarily to get an ECG to fit into a
much smaller space and of course as you
increase the number of wavelets right
two three four and then of course it did
five levels we get our original signal
so that's the trick with wavelets you
can find different components within it
and of course in the case which makes
plenty of sense for an ECG the reason
why like the first wavelet obviously
have a really short definition of our
QRS complex it's a very large part of
that signal there's another nice feature
is that usually I mean granted there's a
lot of theory about choosing the right
wavelet decompose a signal usually the
first wavelets give you the major
component of what's going on and
similarly if you ignore the first
wavelet and you go with the rest to the
end then it will complain we'll ignore
that I actually didn't try that before
the presentation so there we are we've
got a signal we've pre-processed it now
we're going to onto something useful
with it's let's classify some feature
from E to G and make some
so I'm not going to use my HCG I thought
originally I take loads of each D
recording tray loads but actually it is
more useful to you guys to point out
physio net so if you want to work on
physiological datasets physio net is the
first place to go it's a huge great
repository of signals but crucially they
are annotated by hand and clinically
validated so things like the peaks of
the ECG are one there for you so if you
want to try for instance to run some
sort of routine to classify peaks and
ezg and check how well it was so you can
build a cost function then this gives
you a really decent supervised training
set to go from the way that you connect
to it is you can use our sink and I now
know why this doesn't work because I'm
using rsync protocol but ordinarily you
can do arcing at the physio net org and
it would then give you a manifest of all
the physiological signals that available
and of course the reason it's not
working it's using the port that's
blocked so we'll ignore that and come
back to it later the one that I pulled
out of there was the Qt database
ironically I didn't go on to do an asset
on QT in this presentation because I
felt this was too much of a divergence
but the QT is an important measure for
cardiac repolarization it's a main stay
of looking at whether drug-related
effects are going to cause serious
ventricular arrhythmia the way that you
get these signals in is that the RF DB
package which someone has used to wrap
all the tools that come with physio net
gives you the VIN to read the data out
and also some sort of simple plotting
libraries so it allows you to some thing
loss to the side yeah of which you get
both the signal record which you can
print out and there is also a very
useful dictionary although I don't think
I've run this so that won't work
there we go so you get all of the
metadata along with the physiological
signal as well which is particularly
important to being able to do inference
on it be able to classify or categorize
it beforehand
like I say that's partly moods and why I
wanted to put a big shout-out to physio
net if you want to get hold of data of
physiological signals as more than just
ECG it has as many data sets as they've
got some of them are very large indeed
which can get you to sort of the N
numbers that you need to perform
statistical analysis now finding peaks
in the data is usually the the simplest
way of doing is to run a window through
your signal and then do logistic
regressions on the window that you've
got and this is all made a lot useful
for you by using the peak utils library
so peak details as I sort of showed
earlier has a various function called
index you give it a signal that you have
and you can specify some useful
parameters in which case I think it's
only those two threshold a minimum
distance and the distance between each
peak you expect to find
and what threshold is a normalized minus
one to one now zero to one of the signal
you can then use that to to find the
peaks from the signal so in this case
this finds all of our our Peaks very
simply the our peak is very very large
compared to everything else so
ordinarily when you're doing your
pre-processing it's anything you can to
make the peak that you want to see nice
and large and then you can run a very
simple peak finding algorithm over it
piggy tails is using all of the num PG
up governs so it runs really really fast
doesn't run as fast as some of the stuff
you can find in MATLAB it runs fast
enough all the stuff that I've done to
perfectly honest and if you're doing on
very large data sets you can you can you
can shop a signal into multiple parts
and it's an embarrassingly parallel
problem to do you cut your signal to
multiple bits further over nodes it's
very easy to speed this up and the
algorithm is simple enough to do that so
here we found our Peaks which is very
nice and yes as I've sort of pre-emptive
myself smoothing the signal beforehand
can also help find those Peaks if it
wasn't going to work particularly well
one of the smoothing functions if you
not seen familiar with them
you
blinds are generally quite nice on
physiological data so I tend to use them
for quick prototyping the one problem
with any sort of aggregate window which
goes over the signal is that it's going
to cause a little bit of translation of
the signal so you lose the absolute time
point where it occurred so what I
recommend is when you do smooth is you
you run your peak detecting error and
over your smooth signal but then project
that back over your raw signal to see
exactly where it's occurred so in the
same way they can run that and we get
the same thing now granted I should have
chosen the best dataset there was
noisier where one of them didn't occur
and then the other one that did occur
but that's effectively how you improve
that's a the chief way of improving your
peak detection algorithms is by
appropriate smoothing now there is a
function inside of the signal package
inside of scipy which doesn't like this
for you with fine peaks CWT so it's the
CWT bit refers to convolutional wavelet
sorry continuous wavelet transform it
does convolution in a continuous way so
the reason why I recommend peaky tails
is it has some easier to understand
parameters in terms of thresholds and
distance in the rest of it which CWT
doesn't do wavelet transforms are all
about trying to find a particular Ridge
and edge which matches against the way
that you've got so you've then got to do
further details to piece out okay I've
got lots of peeps now I want to separate
out all the ones that I have so of
course in our Sigma we have here where I
run this the CWT algorithm because I
haven't I can't specify the threshold
the rest of it first and all sort of the
important Peaks in my data one thing it
doesn't show you I realize because it's
not in the default parameters it's using
the Riccar wavelet in order to smooth
that Ricca seems to work well for lots
of different problems and this is a fun
thing about wavelets it's the same way
that that works in decompressing images
it's the same waiver that works quite
nicely in ECG signal and in this case
you can run this one so one function
from Sify and it gives you a pretty good
detection of all the major peaks that
you'd want to know inside of the ECG
beyond that you could do further
refinements being as fine those but for
the moment that's a very side way of
finding all the peaks in this particular
signal and the other thing that you'd
want to do of course is that
as a strategy find the our peak first
and then look backwards and look
forwards so in this case what I've done
is I've marked in blue and marked in red
where I expect to find a pea peak and we
expect to find a tea peak so of course
just looking over that data that fits
fairly nicely and then of course I've
left it as an exercise for the reader
you can then run peak details either as
part of that or user the user discrete
wavelet transform over that to smooth
that signal and do the rest of it the
one thing that's interesting about
wavelets is often different wavelets
work better in different situations so
the QRS complex is a very sharp peak one
way that's going to work well for that a
different way that's going to work well
for the P peak and a T beak and to get
the very very high accuracies that we
can get in primary research it uses kind
of iterative strategy in order to be
able to find each peak and classify them
ok so we've got our features we've
classified them on there with all our
peaks a healthy state is kind of a hard
thing to define even large working
groups don't come up with normative
values you can really make use of it's
usually expected in a in a
pharmaceutical trial in just in
healthcare in general that if you want
to do a experiment you need to you
either get a control group or you if you
can if it's a if it's a if it's an
experiment we're giving the treatment
doesn't cause an effect later you can
use them as their own control group and
there are all sorts of things you have
to consider especially for the ECG it
changes based on your age your size
physically but also the size of your
heart your gender affects it so women
who are pre menopausal tend to have a
slower heart rate but just by the effect
of each gene on the effect of their
endocrine system and of course now that
women have access to the the PMT
treatments starting to lose what that is
called that's helped to improve their
cardiovascular health with regards to
that and usually when you're measuring
the ECG you're measuring someone at
rests which when they're sitting because
when you're standing that changes things
because of how your your heart has to
pump your blood against your now
standing body and you would take that as
your normative values generally that's
that is the opinion of the
working taskforce that was set up in the
EU but if you're looking for normative
values you can find them very used by
giving them and of course for a human
heart you're looking at somewhere in the
region of 60 to 80 beats of which a max
of say 200 is pretty darn high and as
low as kind of 40 you can see I remember
famously Eddie Marek one of the one of
the Tour de France winners had a resting
heart rates about 46 so often it can be
used as an indicator of cardiovascular
fitness in his case he just had a very
large heart which perhaps also
predispose them to be a very good
cyclist because he had therefore lots of
capacity and cardiovascular system so
one of the things that we're going to
calculate is the heart rate variability
it is something which is very easy and
tractable to calculate but has lots of
things we can infer from it so this
paper in circulation is actually the
reference to the working group I
probably should've put the citation out
I have good I will publish afterwards so
you can see all this even this 1996
circulation that's not that old for
cardiology papers which is looking
normative value so this is still I would
argue the de-facto reference for it so
calculate heart rate we've gotten our
peaks we've used peak details to find
them the RR interval you can find by
doing the first difference of all the
our peaks in your in your signal so num
P has a very useful thing called if of
which if you give it no other parameters
it does a first order dear for second
third fourth and then once you've got
that you usually express heart rate as
beats per minute so 60 divided by the
hour intervals
I've already rejected heart rates that I
think are out of bounds and simple
measure run it all together and plot it
and here we go this is a fairly typical
heart rate signal yes some of the peaks
are probably misclassified but you will
have sung in a situation where suddenly
you think all gosh the heart rates gone
up perfectly natural the heart rate or
the heart beating makes loads of
mistakes as it goes along but it turns
out it's actually not so bad in fact
there was a very large study where they
were trying class 1 and here with mix
which are deliberately trying to block
common arrhythmias more common in men
than in women for things like premature
of ventricular contraction
and if you actively apply drug
intervention to try and stop the
arrhythmias occurring it actually caused
a right of rise in mortality
we're not entirely sure why that is but
suffice to say the human heart is very
good at making mistakes that really are
causing huge problems so you expect to
see a spiky signal a bit like this once
you have that you can then calculate
heart rate variability which of course
embarrassingly it's basically just the
standard deviation is kind of the main
thing that we use so the cheapest and
trickiest way I did write a stats model
thing I thought that's a bit long
pandas makes this a lot easier for you
so I just threw the heart rate that I
had in front of data frame and do the
describe method and that gives you
decent statistics that are running there
a heart rate variability that's kind of
normal in terms of according to the
circulation paper it's usually quoted in
milliseconds which is about 170
milliseconds which as a reference
it's abouts of eight to ten beats so the
heart rate variability within a sort of
them Wow again this varies as well
within a 30-second one minute window if
your heart beat varies up-and-down but
sort of 10 beats per minute
that's that's fine it really is now now
we can calculate heart rate and heart
rate variability what can we say about
it so one of the main things you use is
for is for determining of diseases so
you can get your heart rate variability
will go down in the event at any one of
these particular diseases so card in my
Appa thie which is where partly heart
died occurs because you have a signal
from your brain which comes down from
your vagus nerve is decreased or the
effectiveness is decreased so your heart
rate tends to go at the speed that's
automatically done so if you're if
you're you have your heart as controlled
both by neurological signals and it does
it automatically less of your
neurological signals are getting in
there it causes your heart Ribbit's to
go down diabetic neuropathy for a
similar reason the nerves that are
attached to your hearts have become
damaged so then that signal doesn't get
through as well a recent transplant
because your heart has that you put the
heart back in connect it all up and then
it's the body that connects the nerves
back together in the event of the
transplant the surgeon doesn't sew those
back onto the heart because that's
impossible at the moment at least and
then liver cirrhosis is another one you
can see from this so if you
I'm drunk too much basically way too
much I mean not just too much loads it
can eventually lead to ink S&OP a--they
and it kept allopathy again affects the
central nervous system effects of
control the heart so all of these things
kind of neatly come together so there's
a lot of things you can see just from
that one measure drug interactions as
well is another interesting the thing
that we look at so of course beta
blockers are acting on the beta
adrenergic receptor on your heart they
slow your heart rate down and
anti-arrhythmic similarly affect the
opening and closing of channels on your
heart so as a result you can see those
new HIV which again I've mentioned a
couple here but this is why if you take
a heart rate measure and because the
heart a measure is something can get
from these smartwatches
there's lots of interesting things that
could possibly be spotted as a result of
just that one measure because anything
that would touch the autonomic nervous
system could have an effect on the HIV
there's things that we can infer and oh
let me go turn that from mark down into
that big go we also use these as various
health indicators so low heart rate and
stable HIV is considered a healthy thing
to have exercise so when your exercise
your heart rate goes up the speed of
which comes back down and recovers it's
going to is a good sign of high
performing cardiovascular activity and
the thing that I'll be involved in and
my new role of Felix is in the
indication of stress so of course when
people get stressed
it's a emotionally stressed it can
eventually have psychosomatic symptoms
of which you get effect on the heart
rate which if you look at any of the
smart watches which are out on the
market they will possibly claim there
are measures of stress that they're
getting inside of there full of quackery
so we're going to try and attempt to
kind of break that apart but this is
kind of the fun thing is it's one
measure
we've been out of find and there's all
sorts of things as serious
cardiovascular diseases we can see there
are effects of drug interactions but
also health indicators we could be quite
useful so HR and HIV are particularly
split in that way now look there we go
[Music]
there we go so we are a machine learning
conference and I realized I haven't
shown you anything that involves machine
learning that's most because even though
I helped organize
pilot in London I actually don't use a
lot of machine learning
I just find it very fascinating so if
you want to if you've got something
fascinating you want to know more about
build a conference where everyone comes
and tells you about it
but the way that it's being used is
generally to improve the feature
extraction from the ECG and the way that
works is that you will use your
convolutional and discrete wavelet
transformations to smooth and create the
signal but then you use machine learning
to match then the wavelet against those
particular shapes of which we're getting
to accuracies you know ninety nine and a
number of nines for getting the the our
peak it's particularly important if
you're going to do this as a medical
device to be able to get to a very very
high degree of certainty
unfortunately medicine generally are
board's probabilities if it can help it
so having more and more certainties
roughly what you maybe even get into the
door so it's it's nice to see that these
techniques are coming I don't know of
any commercial system in the hospital
will be using it this stuff because it's
just it takes so long to get in there
you have to do a clinical trial to prove
your thing is better and it costs a lot
of money but what I found more
fascinating is that someone applied a
long-term short-term memory model to
health records in the US and they were
able in a number of cases to predict the
disease the patient had from the notes
that are taken by the doctors which is
fascinating I mean we're not at the
point where the machine will do it for
us but if it can at least help with the
judgment of diagnosis lsdm in many ways
fits the kind of mental model a doctor
does to infer the diseases he has to
take information that occurred recently
information that kind of while ago and
applying weight to what one's more
important so i sorry recommend this
particular article it's open access
which is fantastic that's up on axes and
if someone afterwards can come and
explain lsdm to me I did have an
exciting LS TM chunk which I nicked off
someone and github which I thought I'll
make my presentation around this I still
don't understand what's going on so
that's why I need someone to come help
me users care asks that's popular right
so yeah if you want to get really at the
edge of working cardiology the computing
and cardiology content is fantastic
they've put on challenges every single
year they've had things like detecting
sudden cardiac death syndrome which we
now know has a much tighter rate
correlation to HIV and yeah if if you
want to get in with these people it's a
lot of MATLAB but I imagine every time
interchange but yeah so that's why I
recommend you would go if you're more
interested it has the hardest problems
they post them up as problems it's a fun
place to be that's all I've got time for
so if you have any questions I'm not
taking
[Applause]
zero I tried to tease out of the rest
what it is good but actually the term is
actually doable that the heart rate
variability that actually planned all
people for example when those officials
are trying to another kind of signal you
can look at it Pikachu
so this optical job which is done with
family before deliver and what those of
you looking at when deciding included to
a society introduce heart rate
variability it's an indication for doing
the Silurian section complete over be
kept upon what the strength though is
that energy of course is not only in
life so it is a 12-lead ECG when you
live your life if you can look at yes so
I thought about whether I would do a big
12 lead ECG and how you put all those
bits together but I figured that I set
up an entire talk just with that so a 3d
CG for the is kind of for the hobbyist
is the first thing to start with
you're quite right like you would want
to in the analysis that I have done
before we were doing this in Collier
toxicology studies a 12-lead ECG to find
also for the key onset and offset points
the key RS but also for the QT interval
getting the really tight the ends and
the beginnings you also look at that you
also look at things like the the shape
of the the peak its morphology how it
changes over time and things like that
so the 12 ECG helps you control for
spatial effects that occur as the heart
rotates slightly as it beats and which
gets worse as it has a beats faster and
harder so yes not including this talk
yes though certain something that helps
you improve your observation of it I
should point out as well my my friend
here is a medical doctor
he's not just a very well read data
scientist so if you have questions of
that nature he's a good one to go to
sure so for the for the pre-processing
that I have done on this plantation know
one of the funny things well Lda
to me means linear discriminant analysis
because in signal processing and I know
it means something like latent something
else in it you do mean linear
discriminant Alice's yeah it works
really nicely because of course yeah you
look at the particular onset and then
you can use that then find the peak
train that over a series of ECG
waveforms cut them into epochs and use
those yeah it works very nicely yeah I
figured that that would be something you
could then follow on to but you usually
then create a talk that was just focused
on the various methods you can use to
improve peak detection within a signal
but yes LD has worked very nicely km's
work more useful with the features to
classify afterwards because the ECG has
both temporal and frequency effects so
it's nicer to analyze in that domain
whereas KNN generally yeah spatial
effects between various categories all
those techniques work well and often the
sad thing is that so I my backgrounds in
pharmacology and you generally don't get
taught this ordinarily you have to go
find this yourself so eventually this
will come through and you know the
products that my friend mentioned are
coming through basically on this nature
as well so yeah there's lots tractor
methods beautif it's just at I'm serious
at the end of the day I see for the work
that I've done that's a really good
question
it's depend on which one's more valid
ironically it wasn't ever asked of me in
a professional setting it was kind of
fine the peaks and get the basic
statistics and that's enough
one of the things you have to understand
a pharmaceutical so you don't really
want to go any further because you might
find something which you don't want to
know and if you and if you and if you
find it's fat it is really sad but if
you find that out you're you are bound
by ethics to report it so often the
method is to just not do anything more
and you've done because then I didn't
know because I didn't see it it's often
what lawyers will do as well it starts
telling something's incriminating I go
sorry I can't hear this otherwise you
know I'm going to have to report it and
it's exactly that unfortunately but sane
computing cardiology is primary research
so they are trying to find exciting new
ways of doing it and particularly
because we can find all sorts of thing
if anything impinges on the autonomic
nervous system the beating of your heart
your breathing rate you can see it in
your heart rate and your HIV so it's an
important measure for all sorts of
things of which you need more and more
sensitive and continuous information of
which the better you can find the
features and classify them then the more
sensitive and possibly the more range of
things we can infer and find over time
EMG right so EMG stands for
electromyograph or my my cardiogram my
no not my Italian just Maya Graham yeah
in my ography my o is the Latin for
muscle so EMG to see electric
let's go activity of the muscle and
ordinarily as a signal it's just a big
noisy signal and you're looking for when
it turns on and when it turns off and
the relationship between the two of them
granted that the heart is a muscle so
that's your it's really kind of EMG
that's specific to the heart but your
muscles that are in your bicep are
different muscles Australian muscles as
opposed to your cardiac muscles they're
they're different so you observe
different patterns from them was there
anything else about how you want to
relate them just what the sort of it's
kind of a specialized version but you
wouldn't ordinarily consider the two
together yeah
sure yeah so the heart rate variability
is a measure of variance of the heart
rate itself so once you've the distance
student difference between the peaks is
the heart rate and then the heart
variability is the variance around that
yes so for instance the Qt peak then how
much that there is the sign of
instability as is the name it's a triad
method so it's look for the
triangulation of the T peak you look at
the repolarization effects which you
have to look at another signal and then
of course it's the instability of how
that moves so yes kind of the
variability of each of those peaks has
inferences for physiology of which the P
wave will be instability within your
atria the the T Picard's is instability
in repolarization which could be either
a drug interaction or it could be
something in built-in endogenous and the
QRS complex as well if that starts
bearing that's very serious because that
really should be very simple and
straight if it widens as well it's a
sign that you've got odiogo doctor in
the ribbon so I can't remember
could be failure cardiac failure Oh fine
I'm not going to say because it's
probably I'm probably liable that
diagnosis safety check sorry
I mean yeah so right so in the ways I've
done it you take you rigid I guess
that's why I've never tried it because
I've always I've always gone with
finding the features of like the peaks
and stuff according them my features and
then applying my machine learning on the
distribution of heart rates heart rate
variability cutie cutie variability
things of this nature
in the time series I'm not entirely sure
so I guess if you were looking at things
like arrhythmias and you were finding a
way for a machine learning classifier to
pick out arrhythmias that worked quite
well because the signal-to-noise ratio
should be quite high in ordinary people
most normal people will have premature
ventricular contractions so I'm pretty
sure if you ran gosh I can't think of a
method to choose that would be so when
I've used SVM's before they've been
fairly useful I doing this kind of work
so if you run SDM classifiers over you
take each ECG as a sample the training
set and use that thing classify that
into categories you can then pick up
arrhythmias once you get to a certain
end number which is quite nice I should
probably do a clock on that yes I find
SVM's weren't quite one of them in that
regard
as in like correlating an ECG with it
with another ECG signal yeah so I guess
because there's so much little
variability and so Auto correlating a
signal is a classic signal processing to
do arguably that's where wavelets are
more sensitive at doing this so
involving a wavelet I tend to find
there's been much more successful yeah I
mean if you if you want to Auto
correlate a signal with itself you can
it's basically we're doing gain which is
quite nice but correlation two signals
together I find it's quite useful if you
want to do alignment between two signals
so you want to line them on the beats
problem there of course is those bits
very so it's generally it's a way you
get something you could do never found
it useful
yeah well I guess this is an unfortunate
case where I'm certainly interested in
the area I have not found in when I've
been working pharmaceuticals their
demand for that in fact in one job I was
working for a biotech started write
software for them and the main investor
said do you want to come work in a
software company instead they said ok
then and did something completely
different computing and cardiology
arguably is doing this kind of stuff so
we're trying to take a more data-driven
approach to analysis of physiological
signals yes there's a lot of domain
expertise in the judgment but that's
true of any machine learning so the
thing you get out at the end of it
inferring whether that's real or true or
whatever comes with a burden of
knowledge of that domain and hopefully I
mean the the low-hanging foods kind of
already already getting is applying
these machine learning things to
instance to do image analysis to find
tumors like it you can get the Machine
say I think this is a tumor doctoring
come along and draw their eyes to get oh
yeah there is a tumor and this kind of
thing it's sort of judgment assisted
kind of computer learning as for where
there is a place for doing this it can
be a really hard to find it be for how
you describe as well it's like the
there's a lot of proprietary knowledge
our medical devices anyway so finding
exactly how the method is used there
isn't a lot of sort of open hardware at
that level open hardware the lower end
but you need quite honest data clinical
validation becomes a big point as to
whether you can actually use it and
actually sell it under such so there
generally are lots of different groups
depends on which bit of physiology
because that's the other thing as well
then lots of stuff with cardiovascular
stuff I don't know too much about I
don't know endocrine pharmacology or
neuropharmacology things like that lots
of super special things but yeah
cardiology is one the ones that's more
amenable to data analysis and not people
in there arguably generally for any of
the kind of electrophysiology generally
has a lot of data on approaches so EEG
EMG or they all the EEG
use and ECGs and the rest of it they
tend to have groups that are built
around those of which I can point you to
any one of those given ones but there's
lots of them thank you
[Applause]
[Music]